-Hello, everyone,
and welcome to another
special social distancing
episode of "Late Night."
As you can see
from the backdrop behind me,
I have moved from my hallway
to my private study
where I sit at night
in a smoking jacket
with a glass of brandy pondering
life's great mysteries.
It looks kind of like this.
Eureka.
And as you can also see,
I own my very own
"back in my day" sweater
that I wear unironically,
so ya burnt! me.
And to be clear, this is
definitely my private study
and not a garage I've been
relegated to
because my family has told me
on no uncertain terms
I'm not allowed to do
my little political rants
at the dinner table.
Now, I hope you're
all staying at home
self-distancing and doing
your part to slow the spread,
despite the fact that
our unhinged president
would like to ignore the crisis
and return to normal
as soon as possible.
For more on this.
It's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Donald Trump sees everything
as a transaction.
His first question is always,
"What do I get out of this?"
It's what he asked
when he was building casinos.
It's what he asked when they
offered him "The Apprentice,"
and it's what he asked
when Eric was born.
[ As Trump ] Great.
What's in it for me?
[ Normal voice ] And even
the doctor was like,
"Oh, literally nothing.
Nothing. This is a straight-up
loss for you."
That's what happened when
he got impeached, remember?
You remember that?
That huge world historical event
that happened approximately, I
don't know, like 307 years ago.
Talking about the impeachment of
Donald Trump feels like talking
about going to RadioShack
to pick up a Walkman,
to listen to the new
Tears for Fears album.
"Back in my day."
It was less
than four months ago,
but it feels like it happened
right around the same time
Trump popped up
in "Home Alone 2."
[ As Trump ] Yeah, I hope
you find your parents, kid,
but first, you know where I can
get some dirt on Joe Biden?
[ Normal voice ] It feels
impossible to remember this now,
but the federal response to
a deadly and highly infectious
global pandemic is being
overseen by a president
who was impeached less than
four months ago
for trying to use foreign aid
to a war-torn country
to benefit himself politically.
As you may recall,
immediately after the aid
came up on his phone call
with the newly elected president
of Ukraine,
Trump literally said the words,
"I would like you
to do us a favor, though."
And of course,
Trump is the kind of guy
who asks you for a favor
before he's even met you.
He's like a guy messaging
a girl he just met on Tinder.
"Would love to meet you.
Can I crash at your place
for a few days?
I have a fever and a cough.
And my roommate kicked me out
for using their toothbrush.
Also, my roommate is my wife
and I have five kids."
So everything with Trump
is a transaction
in which he seeks
to personally benefit himself,
whether it's foreign aid
to a war-torn country
or a global pandemic.
For example,
after he was criticized
by New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo for not sending
the state enough ventilators
from the federal stockpile,
Trump lashed out by claiming it
was a two-way street
and that governors had to earn
help from the federal government
by being nice to him.
-We're building them hospitals.
We're building
a medical centers.
And he was complaining
about we're doing
probably more definitely
more than anybody else.
But he shouldn't
be talking about us.
He's supposed to be buying
his own ventilators.
We're going to help.
We're working very, very hard
for the people of New York.
We're working along with him.
And then I watch him on the show
complaining.
We are doing very well with,
I think,
almost all of the governors
for the most part.
I think we're doing very well.
But, you know,
it's a two-way street.
They have to treat us well,
also.
-No, they don't. It's your job.
They don't owe you anything
for doing your job.
States don't pay tribute
to the president.
[ As Trump ] What gifts have
arrived for me today?
[ Normal voice ] Well,
Mr. President,
Alaska sent timber.
Maryland sent crabs.
[ As Trump ]
And what of New York?
[ Normal voice ] They set the
most magnificent creature, sir.
He is half-man, half-baseball.
[ As Trump ]
How amusing. Yes. Yes.
Send them two ventilators
in return.
[ Normal voice ]
What makes you like this?
This guy is so insecure
and self-obsessed,
he demands constant praise
and validation
simply for doing
the bare minimum.
And if he doesn't get it, he'll
just thank himself in a tweet.
Imagine being America's
dumbest person
somehow getting
the highest office in the land
and still thinking
you're owed something.
He's like a dog
who expects a treat
every time you [bleep]
in the yard.
When you let him back
in the house,
he goes straight to the closet
and sits there
until you toss him a McNugget.
In fact, The Daily Beast
reported this week
that Trump views his response
to the pandemic
purely through the lens
of who's being nice to him.
And as a result of that,
he's been swinging wildly
back and forth,
depending on what Cuomo says
about him on any given day.
A person who spoken to the
president earlier this month
recounted that one day, Trump
had mentioned in a meeting
how well Cuomo was behaving
in handling the crisis,
Only to two days later,
start bashing the governor
in a different private
conversation as "nasty."
There's no telling which Trump
you're going to get
on any given day.
One day, he'll be
your best friend.
The next day, he'll hate you.
It's like we're trapped
in the movie "Fight Club."
One day,
we're going to see Trump
kicking the crap out himself
in the White House parking lot.
[ As Trump ]
The first rule of fight club --
I get 20 percent of all bets.
[ Normal voice ] Also, I really,
truly hate that Trump
uses the word "nasty" as an
insult because it ruins
what could otherwise be
a fun word.
Just once, I'd like to see him
get up at the podium
and use it the way
Raven-Symoné would use it.
[ As Trump ] Everyone remember,
don't cough into your hands
'cause that's nasty!
[ Normal voice ] The president
is supposed to be
a public trust.
You're supposed to be able
to distinguish between
your own personal interests
and the duties of the office.
Now, sure, every president
gets something out of it.
Maybe they use it to meet girls
or they get a nice Netflix deal.
They might even use it to score
a sweet job in real estate.
95 years old
and still building houses.
Jimmy Carter is the yin
to Trump's yang.
It's like he has to do
a good thing
for every bad thing Trump does.
One house at a time.
Every time Trump tweets,
Jimmy says,
[ As Carter ]
Better get my tool belt.
[ Normal voice ] So, yes, there
are benefits to being president,
but Trump is taking it
to an insane level.
He pathologically is incapable
of grasping anything
other than his own survival.
In fact, CNN reported this week
that Trump is considering
reopening the country
prematurely in the middle
of a deadly pandemic,
partially because he personally
is bored inside the White House.
-I want to bring in CNN's
Caitlin Collins
live for us
from the White House.
Caitlin, sources tell you
that the president
is feeling increasingly isolated
at the White House
and questioning, eager
to have life returned to normal.
-Yeah, he feels like he's been
cut off from the outside world,
much like the rest of the nation
and other parts of the world
feel as they are responding
to this staying home.
-Hey, man, welcome to the club.
We're all stuck inside.
Why don't you just
do what we're all doing
and put on your sweatpants,
watch four episodes
of "Tiger King,"
try to do an online workout,
give up,
and just drink wine out of a
cereal bowl until you pass out.
You're not the only one
being inconvenienced.
Normally, I'd be doing my show
from a well-lit studio
in midtown Manhattan
for 200 people,
but instead,
I'm here in my house
trying to get my dog
to laugh at my jokes.
I got people on Twitter telling
me I'm worse at YouTube videos
than their teenage daughters.
Well, no [bleep]
I'm 46, which probably
won't surprise you
now that you see
what I look like
when I'm doing my own makeup.
Also, teenage girls
are great at YouTube
and I know because I spent
half the day
watching makeup tutorials
on how not to look
like a ghost in a bookstore.
And do you know how hard it is
to tell a 4-year-old
"Daddy has to go make
one of his videos."
I mean, it's true,
but it sounds like a lie.
It sounds like what you'd say
before going to the garage
to drink alone.
[ Slurring ]
I gave 'em hell today, buddy.
I gave 'em hell in my video.
[ Normal voice ] Yesterday,
I had a take ruined
because a bird wouldn't shut up.
You know how bad things are when
you're having bird troubles?
They're bad.
So I'm sorry you're bored,
stuck in America's
most famous house
that has its own personal chef
in a bowling alley.
Boo-hoo.
In fact, CNN also reported
that Trump is so bored
in the White House
he's actually been
going to meetings
like everyone working from home.
Trump has shown evidence
of cabin fever,
crashing meetings of
his coronavirus task force,
inserting himself
in planned press conferences
during daily policy sessions.
Aides say they sometimes
don't know whether Trump
will walk through the door,
leading to a general level
of uncertainty
on what to place on the agenda.
So the answer to the riddle,
"How do you get the president
to go to a meeting?"
is a [bleep] pandemic.
But of course,
he makes meetings worse.
It's amazing to think that
if you want to do
the actual work of government
in the Trump era,
you have to hide like a teenage
boy with a copy of "Maxim."
[ Whispering ]
So as you can see here,
maximizing testing capacity
is the most efficient way
to flatten the curve --
Oh, crap! Someone's in here!
Someone's in here!
[ Normal voice ] And there
must be a huge difference
between having Trump
in the meeting
and not having him
in the meeting.
If he's not there, you can
dive deep into the weeds
of public health
and epidemiology.
If he's there, you have to
rewrite the agenda
so the first item is --
"Coronavirus. Did Obama start it
alone or did Hillary help?"
[ As Trump ] My personal take
is it looks like a two-man job.
But you guys are the scientists.
Okay.
I'm going to go give
the Lincoln portrait
another shaving cream beard.
I'm gonna groom you, Lincoln!
[ Normal voice ] Also,
it's really gotta suck
for everyone else
in the White House
now that Trump is trapped inside
and showing up to meetings.
it's like trying to
work from home
while babysitting your kids.
Next time Mike Pence
Skypes into a meeting,
Trump's gonna wander
into the room behind him
in a baby walker.
Well, Trump apparently
resented the implication
that he was bored while holed up
in the White House
because yesterday he lashed out
on Twitter,
writing "I hear that fake news
CNN just reported
that I am isolated
in the White House,
wondering out loud when life
will return to normal.
Does anybody really believe
that?
There was no leak.
They made it up.
They are corrupt and fake news.
I've been packed all day
with meetings.
I have no time for stupidity."
This is the age of coronavirus.
Being packed in meetings
is stupidity.
[ As Trump ]
So many meetings today.
Each one with more people.
Each one in a smaller room,
sharing one pen.
[ Normal voice ] Stupidity
is all you have time for.
You spend so much time
on stupidity,
you literally got the country's
leading infectious
disease expert,
the widely respected doctor
in charge of fighting
a global pandemic
to touch his face
in exasperation
during one of your inane
press conferences.
That's how annoying you are.
You made the guy whose job
it is
to tell people not to touch
their faces, touch his face.
It's like getting a librarian
to yell at you.
"Shut the [bleep] up!"
"Karen, I've never heard you
raise your voice before."
"He just -- He broke me."
"How?!"
"He just kept holding up
'Moby Dick' and asking me..."
[ As Trump ] Do you get it?
But do you?
[ Normal voice ] Nonetheless,
it's clearly the case that Trump
is desperate to prematurely
stop the fight
against the coronavirus pandemic
in order to appease
the stock market,
because when
the green arrow goes up,
all the business schools around
him tell him how great he is.
And that's what he lives for.
If someone could just show him
the chart of coronavirus cases
in the U.S. and tell him
it's the Dow Jones...
[ As Trump ]
We did it, you guys.
High five, high five.
What? Why not?
Oh, right, right.
The Sharona virus.
From the meeting.
[ Normal voice ]
Trump doesn't care for a minute
that the outbreak
is accelerating,
growing deadlier by the day.
Nurses and doctors
on the front lines
have compared hospitals
to war zones
and called
the situation apocalyptic.
And yet on Wednesday,
Trump suggests the media
was trying to force him to keep
public health restrictions
in place
to hurt him politically.
-Let me put the tweet up.
"The lamestream media
is the dominant force
in trying to get me
to keep our country closed
as long as possible in the hope
that it will be detrimental
to my election success.
The real people want
to get back to work ASAP.
We will be stronger
than ever before.
-You think this is all
a big conspiracy
to hurt your re-election
chances? You know what?
If you think it's all a
conspiracy, then why don't you
go outside and ask a bunch
of people to cough on you.
Just go out onto the streets
of D.C. with a mic
and give people a dollar
to cough on you.
You can call it
"Bully on the Street."
This is a truly dangerous moment
to have a paranoid narcissist
who's incapable of grasping
anything
other than his own self-interest
in charge
of the federal government.
In fact, yesterday, as the
outbreak was only accelerating
and healthcare professionals
were begging for supplies,
the president decided it was
a good time to pat himself
on the back and pick fights
with multiple reporters.
-You said that the media wants
the country to remained closed.
-Yeah, yeah, no,
the media would like to
see me do poorly
in the election.
I think -- I think --
-Lawmakers on both sides
of the aisle have said that
reopening the country by Easter
is not a good idea.
What is that plan based on?
-Just so you understand.
Are you ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-I think there are certain
people that would like it
not to open so quickly.
I think there are certain people
that would like it
to do financially poorly
because they think
that would be very good as far
as defeating me at the polls.
I think it's very clear
that there are people
in your profession
that write fake news.
You do. She does.
There are people in your
profession that write fake news.
We've done one hell of a job.
Nobody's done the job
that we've done.
And it's lucky that you have
this group here
right now for this problem.
Well, you would even have
a country left.
-I'm sorry, but why the hell
are we still airing
these things?
He's not saying anything
valuable.
He's just calling out reporters
one by one,
like an insult comic
at [bleep] night club.
[ As Trump ] Women love to shop.
This lady knows
what I'm talking about.
Also, she nasty!
[ Normal voice ] We wouldn't
have a country left?
I don't know if you've been
outside lately,
but we can't even
go outside lately.
Thanks to you,
we barely have a country left.
We have pieces of a country.
Trump's like the house sitter
you hire
who throws a party at your place
while you're gone
and when you get back,
hands you a plastic bag
full of pieces
of an expensive vase.
"All the pieces are there.
You just, uh --
You need to glue New Jersey
back on to Pennsylvania.
And on top of the fact
that we have a president
lying about
a public health crisis
and spreading
dangerous misinformation,
some in the Republican Party
also tried to use the crisis
to punish working Americans.
A group of GOP senators
objected to a provision
in the stimulus bill
that gives workers $600 extra
on top of their usual
unemployment benefits
and introduced an amendment
last night to strip that out,
claiming it would incentivize
people to go on unemployment
rather than go back to work.
-The moment we can go back
to work,
we cannot create an incentive
for people to say,
"I don't need to come back
to work
because I can do better
someplace else."
So we cannot be paying people
more money on unemployment
than what they would
get paid in their job.
-We cannot encourage people
to make more money
in unemployment
than they do in employment.
If you're a nurse aide making
$15 or $16 an hour,
you're on the front lines here.
So you gonna have all these
well-trained nurses.
They're going to make
$24 an hour on unemployment.
You're literally incentivizing
taking people
out of the workforce.
-I'm sorry, you think nurses
who are on the front lines
of a pandemic are suddenly
going to quit their jobs
because they could get
an extra 600 bucks?
Dude, you're telling
on yourself.
All that does is reveal you care
more about money than your job.
[ As Graham ] If someone offered
me 600 bucks,
I'd quit my job
and spend my days
sitting on my porch in my
rocker, drinking a mint julep
in a big straw hat and gossiping
with my dog Biscuit.
You didn't hear it from me,
Biscuit,
but Miss Beauregard cat is
only pretending to be spayed.
She's hoping to get knocked up
by one of those wealthy cats
who live at the country club.
[ Slurping ]
[ Normal voice ] So in response
to that, Senator Bernie Sanders
took to the floor
of the Senate last night
to fight for the expanded
unemployment benefits
in a fiery speech
that he did not hold back.
-And now I find that some of
my Republican colleagues
are very distressed.
They're very upset of somebody
who's making 10,
12 bucks an hour
might end up with a paycheck
for four months
more than they received
last week.
[ Sarcastically ] Oh, my God,
the universe is collapsing!
Imagine that -- somebody
was making 12 bucks an hour.
Now, like the rest of us, faces
an unprecedented economic crisis
with the 600 bucks
on top of their normal,
their regular unemployment check
might be making a few bucks
more for four months.
[ Sarcastically ] Oh, my word!
Will the universe survive?!
-Man, I love --
I love sarcastic Bernie.
It's so refreshing to see
a politician
who's as pissed off
as everyone else is right now.
He lit into those Republicans
like his bratty grandchildren
were complaining they couldn't
look at their phones
at the dinner table.
[ As Sanders ] Oh, oh, my God!
The universe is collapsing!
How will I survive
without my Tiks and my Toks?
You know, when I was young,
we didn't have emojis.
We just had to make
faces ourselves like this.
Now, you know I'm surprised.
[ Normal voice ] The president
is a threat to public health.
He's incapable of distinguishing
between his own
personal interests
and the duties of his office,
and he uses his daily platform
on national TV
to spread misinformation
and air petty grievances.
No one watching
these press conferences
actually learns anything.
In fact, if you watch Trump
talk for any amount of time,
you end up asking yourself
sincerely...
[ Sarcastically ] Oh, my word!
Will the universe survive?!
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.